first bill malusion live at the Border
in Eagle Pass Texas and Bill it was
pretty interesting that 11 p.m on a
Friday night the Press office at
Department of Homeland Security decides
to release some numbers you know 11 p.m
on a Friday night let's just say that's
an unusual time to be releasing a
statement
Dana good morning to you that's exactly
right I'd say it's about as blatant of a
Friday night news drop as you are ever
going to see and keep in mind these
September numbers are the last numbers
the public would get a chance to see
when it comes to the border before the
midterms and those numbers are historic
let's take a look at them right now
September 2022 fiscal year 2022 CBP
reporting more than 227 thousand migrant
encounters that is the highest September
in DHS history the numbers also show
fiscal year 2022 ended with nearly 2.4
million migrant encounters that is the
highest fiscal year ever recorded and
then perhaps most concerning if we can
pull this graphic up fiscal year 2022
ended with 98 border patrol arrests of
people on the FBI's Terror watch list
just to put that number in perspective
for you under President Trump the
highest number of Terra watchless arrest
was six in 2018. President Biden just
had 98 in fiscal year 2022 and and the
numbers are not slowing down take a look
at this video we shot early this morning
here on the north side of Eagle Pass
showing yet another massive group
Crossing illegally well over 100 people
in total in a 24-hour span over the
weekend we had more than 1500 illegal
Crossings and CBP sources tell Fox News
here in this Del Rio sector in just the
first three weeks of October we have
already had more than 29 000 illegal
crossings that represents a 50 percent
increase over the same time last year
then take a look at this Wild video
provided to us by a source out of the
Rio Grande Valley showing a group of
shirtless drug smugglers who have just
come across the border they just swam
across the river they are carrying
bundles of Narcotics in broad daylight
they run up to a waiting vehicle in a
parking lot and they load that vehicle
up with the drugs before they run off
back to Mexico and the driver takes off
well Texas DPS tells us they ended up
getting into a Pursuit with that driver
and they arrested him if we can pull up
these photo those right here that
suspect the driver behind that wheel was
an 18 year old U.S citizen who you can
see is smirking at the camera after they
arrested him he had 10 bundles of drugs
in that vehicle with him he was arrested
and charged but just goes to show there
was no CBP no border patrol to stop
those guys from bringing those drugs in
it was Texas DPS who ended up catching
that drug Smuggler and back out here
live another record at the border fiscal
year 2022 CBP sources tell Fox News
there were
856 migrant deaths that is the highest
number ever recorded and Dana the
startling thing about that almost 2.4
million number that does not include the
600 000 godaways who crossed our border
successfully evading apprehension last
year we'll send it back to you Bill any
other media down there covering this
uh you know what it's it's pretty wild
we actually had print media from Japan
out here this morning and then we just
had a Dutch TV crew come up to us and
ask us where the spots are to find
migrant Crossings so yes there's press
down here they're just not from the
United
thank you so much Bill I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis